now we i would like to welcome dr gus
kasoulis he is a professor of virology
and biotechnology in the department of
pathobiological sciences and director of
the division of biotechnology and
molecular medicine he is the director of
the nih funded center in experimental
infectious disease research and the
director of nih-funded louisiana
biomedical research network molecular
and cell biology code dr gus would be
talking on data science for biological
data a message for the national
association of idea principal
investigators over to you dr kass
so hopefully you can see my screen
yes dr gus we can see your screen okay
well um i guess good morning or good
afternoon depending where you are um
thank you for the introduction i'm very
pleased to participate in this important
symposium it was exciting to see the
opportunities but the elite universities
at georgetown
and also at cmu
very exciting programs
i am the president of the national
association of idea principal
investigators
and
this
is a 503c not-for-profit corporation
there is a think tank
that helps nih and specifically the
national institute of general medical
sciences
to sort of uh socialize uh and support
biomedical research within 23 states in
puerto rico and those 23 states in
puerto rico representing practically
half of the country
are those states that do not receive
high levels of nih funding and nih is
concerned about that and has created
this program
to support biomedical research
and specifically data science and
bioinformatics at the undergraduate and
graduate level with a focus on primary
primarily undergraduate institutions
so navy aims to
as i said be a think tank and advice and
aids on programs and how to really
support biomedical research
and it fosters interactions promotes
resources sharing enhances the
visibility of multiple programs i will
tell you a little bit about
and develops consensus priorities
disseminates best practices and
identifies opportunities and develop
strategies for uh excelling in
biomedical research
this is the leadership of the um nappy i
serve as the president and we have an
executive committee with dr doug wright
uh from kansas
uh dr yan mang uh from the university of
new england dr scott seville from
wyoming and dr julia oxford secretary
from boise state um
we the netbi website i think is part of
my um uh what i have disclosed here and
you could look at an episode uh for uh
all this information about what map is
doing so again the mission of nep is to
provide leadership and communication for
development and promotion improvement of
biomedical research and
as already told you a lot of the goals
is really foster interaction support or
constituents and stakeholders throughout
those programs
so a little bit briefly about the
history of the idea program the national
institutes of health developed
institutional development award or idea
program it was established in 93 to
broaden the geographic distribution of
united's funding for biomedical
behavioral research
the program fosters health-related
research and enhances the
competitiveness
uh by investing in institutions
located in states which the aggregate
success rate for applications and aids
has historically been law so it is to a
large extent manpower development
socializing support for biomedical
research and supporting uh in
much greater numbers
people that could pursue biomedical
research the program also serves unique
populations such as rural and medically
undeserved communities in this in these
states
so this is just a
brief idea about the funding the current
funding is approximately 400 million
that's distributed among different
programs it started uh much slower in
93 with approximately 30 million and has
been
rising
hopefully hopefully attending up to one
percent of the budget and as you can see
one percent of the nih budget that is
actually distributed for this uh
programs competitive programs in 23
states and puerto rico
and uh this programs have been
fundamental because they increase
competitiveness within the states
and leverages them to be able to compete
with categorical traditional funding by
nih
and
a number of our states because of this
funding have been able to compete and
get significant uh funding by competing
with much more developed institutions
and states
so uh the five idea funding programs uh
uh is the centers of biomedical research
excellence discoveries
uh this program is really targeting to
graduate individual investigators with
r1 funding from nih and has been
fantastically successful
having
investigators reaching the first r1 at
younger age
in comparison to the average across the
states
and also promoting excellence of
biomedical research within specific
institutions
the imbre awards uh for which one i'm
the principal investigator is a
different type of award one per state
they had 24 active awards and those have
a targeted focus on
promoting
the uh the promoting biomedical research
through uh
primarily through uh
supporting
the primarily undergraduate institutions
and they have mandatory focus on
training and teaching and providing
support for data science and
bioinformatics and this is what i call
socializing
learning for data science because we'll
reach
more than 50 000 undergraduates and what
are we trying to do through mapping
through these programs is really uh
provide free or very
low cost uh training
in bioinformatics and data science
you also have the idea intervals for
clinical translational research the idea
cprs the 20 active states the focus of
translational research
we also support the nih supports uh
co-funding for our ones in our fifteenth
and has ten applications that come
within region of being funded by
categorical institute and we do have
four hubs that promote entrepreneurship
within the um idea network
so um the idea networks himself
and i will talk about some of the
specific things that nih is doing to
promote uh data science and
computational biology uh through cloud
computing training and through google
and amazon contracts
and the ctrs are clinical translational
centers that involve multiple medical
schools within the idea states
and there's a co-funding coordinator
that has been used to really help
people within states to achieve funding
through a categorical institute
of course the idea regional technology
centers have seen programs and they
teach business fundamentals for
technology for directors called uh the
inbree and kobe programs
uh the number other collaborations and
participations in nih-wide initiatives
i'll go briefly through this and you'll
have the slides to series these are
really from a recent town meeting that
we had with nih dr mingli presented
some of his
information so there is collaborations
among the idea programs there are
supplements that have been given to
cobra ctrs
for a number of different purposes
including a number of them for copy 19
research there are collaborations with
non-idea nice programs including the
maternal infant mortality research uh
the kobe 19 patient registry cloud
computing for biomedical research and
the nih strides program
that involves access to google and
amazon cloud computing and i'll say
something about that a little later
we also have a competing
participation in competition for nih
white resides initiatives including the
active files for program 19 therapeutics
and the rapid acceleration of
diagnostics and front desired
populations
so uh a new program for nih that i think
would be important for some of you to
know is the shure program which is
supported for research excellence uh
sure program and this is really to
target primarily undergraduate
institutions that serve minorities and
it has different programs one is to
support investigators
for nih research funding
and to support research excellence as a
first independent research award
and to build administrative
infrastructure broadening participation
and the uh the specific qualifications
for this up to uh 25
of the [ __ ] of the students being served
by pell grants
it replaces a number of the
opportunities that were provided
initially for minority institutions a
number of really small primarily
undergraduate institutions can compete
for these awards of course the injury
programs within state will assist in any
of those primarily undergraduate
institutions within these 23 states and
puerto rico to submit this competitive
awards to an aids
this again the map of the idea program
states uh that yes i
told you involves the cobras inbreeze
idea ctrs
23 states and puerto rico labeled here
this map as green
uh really there are the states that uh
have
a great population a lot of interest
unfortunately not the resources some of
the bigger states have than the elite
programs throughout the country and
nappies facilitating accessing this
information
and
representing all these idea states to
nih into the federal government
so nappy has done a number of
initiatives and we are in the process of
developing uh more
um
let's get this out of here
uh we were providing funding for idea
undergraduate students to travel to
washington dc every other year we have a
national meeting where over a thousand
people attending in washington dc
and we'll provide travel funds for that
we're awarding awards for undergraduate
graduate and assistant professors for
best presentations in our regional
meetings which are also every other year
uh overlapping um every other year
regional meetings and then the national
meeting the access to idea-wide
databases and we provide
free access to virtual training courses
and exercises created by df faculty and
discounts to other virtual courses in
data science and informatics we have
really
had a collaboration with find biotech
and will we're providing a number of
these courses free of charge or with low
charges throughout our network uh
accessing more than 50 000 students
we also have gonna have job postings and
job searches in the idea program
uh we also were proud that we are
co-sponsors for the this particular
symposium which provides
i think tremendous information for what
has been happening in the field of data
science and training
we're also very proud to announce for
the first time that we are the
recipients of the tober foundation
support a donation that will help us
gather data science by informatics
content including training modules
and lectures and we'll disseminate them
through our website through all the
nappy
stakeholders and participants and we're
going to provide the pine bar tech
material for free or through discounted
prices to all nepa members
also we'll be providing cass awards as i
was telling you for different uh
conferences that we support and we also
will be covering expenses with his
donation for a general lecture on
citizen science which is also very
important
and we'll be covering expenses for
launching surveys and maintaining our
navy website and engaging the nepa
members and organizations into a larger
discussion about how best to train
people especially in data science and
bioinformatics with a goal to
increase competitiveness for biomedical
research
i want to very briefly to also mention
our own program the louisiana biomedical
research network this is the website
here it does have a number of
important information and
recorded lectures on coronal biology and
other symposia that we've held together
with fine biotech
and we also been involved heavily in
summer training and this is the previous
summer program that we launched
with over 10 different uh types of
programs and other than virtual with the
assistance of fine biotech and you'll
find this information in the lbrn
website
and we're very proud that we had a
number of participants doing specific
projects as well as virtual projects
through this
i want to take a really brief time
because i haven't seen that
mentioned here that uh obviously as you
uh you'll gather through my presentation
that nih is very much interested in
really disseminating information
and training people uh the new
generation of scientists in biomedical
research especially data science and
bioinformatics and uh there's a special
office the nih office of data science
strategy has been created this is the
website here data science at the nhl go
i think very important for any of you
that are interested to really
look at that site because it has a lot
of very important information as well as
free webinars and so on and of course
this is as everybody knows the explosion
of
ncbi data and services is noted here so
the amount of information we are
handling is really humongous has been
noted already and that really
necessitates the
need for training people to be able to
really
understand these really large data sets
and be able to derive uh information
that would help for biomedical research
so the strategic plan for data science
which is really on that website that you
could download it
it notes that our nation in the world
stand at a unique moment of opportunity
by medical research and data science is
an integral contributor so
nih recognizes how important this is and
that's why it creates these programs and
trying to engage the entire country not
necessarily only the top elite
institutions
so this is a definition of data science
in the disciplinary field of inquiry in
which quantitative analytical approaches
processes and systems are developed and
used to extract knowledge and insights
from increasingly large and more complex
datasets
and this is part of the third principles
which is really to create datasets that
are findable accessible interparable and
reusable and
you can see all these qualifiers within
the website for the strategic plan of
nih a very important document that
really gives you a blueprint of what nih
will be focusing on the next
five to ten years and beyond
so this is the strategic plan for data
science
it looks into these components for data
infrastructure to modernizing data
ecosystem to data management analytics
and tools the workforce development
and stewardship and sustainability and
the idea program is particularly
focusing
and nepea's efforts are focusing on
workforce development we need to enhance
the nih data science workforce expand
the national research workforce and
engage a broader community because i
don't think
if we really do not socialize these
tools and information and training and
education we won't be
be able to compete at the international
level with other states and countries
that are really focusing a lot on
training their people and competing
at large
with the united states
so um science in the cloud is a very
important
program the
nih created united data commons
it's as a pilot program and that really
creates access to test data sets
including the national heart lung and
blood institute's transomics for
precision medicine
top net and the nih common spawn
genotype tissue expression so these data
bases are really available for mining by
all people and it's part of really
socializing all these data sets to
everybody who may be interested in them
and one of the more important things
that nih is part of the strategic plan
is citizen science and really citizen
science aims to bring science and
science policy processes to the public
to ensure that science is responsive to
public concerns and needs and to harness
additional resources to capture data and
innovation in a wide variety of fields
and a couple examples of
specific
modules have been created the eye wire
which is online resource launched in
2012
that challenges players to map the
three-dimensional structural neurons and
you can find more information about that
at dna's website in the experimental
cities and science training for the next
generation program that promotes
biomedical scientific careers among
k-r-1-12 students and aims to increase
participation of individuals and groups
underrepresented by medical sciences so
um it was very uh wonderful to hear
cmu's elite program georgetown
our goal is to be able to really spread
that information and engage the entire
country
and
specifically to the
cloud computing resources uh cloud
computing sources now being available
for idea states 23 states and puerto
rico and minorities serving institutions
and this is the nih strikes program
science and technology research
infrastructure for discovery
experimentation and sustainability and
this is an agreement of nih with amazon
google and microsoft to be able to
provide discounted cloud services and
training
through these agreements and there is
now a um
working on understanding what the needs
are and there's an rfi
that will expire
in september to find out uh input
for current and future needs and
utilization of cloud computing from
institutions within idea eligible states
rcmis and msis
part of the idea is to provide resources
to the cloud to a lot of these
institutions that do not have local
resources for computational biology and
there are nih workshops on broad in
cloud computing
the next one is september 1314 and there
is a website for registration for all
idea
participants
and there are
33 cloud training days
15 by amazon 15 by google then these are
the specifics of the number of students
that would participate
and uh there's a direct contact with nih
for those people that are within those
23 states of puerto rico that they could
participate
so when i leave you with this
this is my uh uh
last two final slides i would like to
thought of people uh this sport by um
uh harriet pitcher stole that common
sense is the knack of seeing things as
they are and doing things as they ought
to be done
we are striving very hard
to socialize uh training in data science
and bioinformatics and uh hopefully
we'll lift
all our communities to be able to be
much more competitive for biomedical
research
and this is the picture of the lsu
stadium football
two few years back when it was actually
full of people we hope to return back to
normancy
soon and i will welcome any of you if
you would like to visit lsu uh to also
visit us at the brm thank you
thank you dr kasus
we do have a couple of questions so the
first question
is about members of
lbrn about applying to the idea
co-funding for r15 uh what are the what
is the process for that
yeah so um typically obviously we assist
in this through our administrative core
um
but
there is a specific
contact person at the nfgms
and
they need to know and
when you are really within
potentially close to a categorical
funding they are you nominated
to be
cross-funded by ngms and the categorical
institute and typically what happens is
ngms and the idea program picks up the
first
year or not 15 or the first two years or
an hour one and then the categorical
institute picks up the remaining funding
part of the idea is to
allow the categorical institutes to fund
proposals that
did not make the cut
through
the categorical institute so typically
we've seen grants within
five to maybe 10 percentile points
depending on the topic and the interest
finance that could get funded
for these 23 states in puerto rico
okay thank you and another question is
do you collaborate with international
institutions uh for uh research faculty
development student exchange etc
yes um
well you know the the home uh unit that
really administers the louisiana
biomedical research network is the
division of biotechnology molecular
medicine
at lsu
a school of dairy medicine that i direct
and we are
sort of
working
to export a lot of our training in
collaboration with pinecone tech
we have talked to a number of countries
interested in latin america as well as
europe southern europe and
quite soon will be um announcing
a series of training modules
that
are provided right now to only lsu
students internally but we hope to
export
these training modules exercises
potentially a virtual master's degree
to um
international students
with a focus in latin america and
southern europe but this time a
potentially middle east and elsewhere
all right thank you very much
and uh final question is
what do you think is
kind of a way for students without any
bioinformatics background so from maybe
a life science background are there any
summer opportunities for them to join
some of this training
so within these 24 states it's fairly
easily easy because all these inbrief
programs the idea network of american
sex excellence
except
undergraduate students that within those
states
uh
in louisiana we have 27 institutions
that participate in the summer program
and they apply they get in and
they do summer research
and not only in bioinformatics but also
biomedical sciences by really being
hosted a lot of things the last couple
of years have been done virtually very
successfully
if you're not in an idea network
the only opportunities would be for us
at least to lsu our current efforts to
export this
in a larger format uh and nebby is
interested primarily obviously for the
23 states and puerto rico because this
is really our charter to help those 24
states but ultimately
we believe that we could uh sort of
socialize a lot of this training uh
because there's a firm belief within the
network that
these tools and training should be
available to people
at very low cost
and as many people as possible as young
as possible because that's the only way
to really uh have an inversion point as
people say in business to be able to
really transform
education you have to reach out to as
many people as possible and as young as
possible
all right so final question thank you
for that answer
um are there any opportunities for
people working with plant sciences
agriculture and plant breeding
for
you know
learning about bioinformatics and
potentially joining research projects
yeah obviously at lsu where the lsu ag
center a number of students participate
in plant related
bioinformatics computational biology
projects
the students enroll at lsu and the
college of agriculture and we have they
participate in a number of our projects
uh i think it's very possible that we
create um certain virtual projects that
relate to plant science specifically and
we have a number of researchers that are
working on advanced bioinformatics data
science for plant genetics and
plant-related projects so you know um
data science and
biology
includes both plant and eukaryotes in so
many ways so the same tools are used
across the board
whether it's a plant or is actually
another organism
all right great